Hi there, it's Marianne here. Just before we get started, I wanted to quickly let you know about an incredible free masterclass happening this Monday, the 3rd of March at 8pm UK time with my mentor Lisa Johnson. She will be walking us through the 5 key steps you need to add a recurring revenue stream to your business or life using her powerful cash system, CASSH. And trust me, it makes so much sense. Whether you've joined the recent challenge or not, this session is packed with game-changing insights to help you move towards financial freedom. Plus, there's a Q&A session at the end and if you've taken part in the challenge, there are epic prizes to be won. And if you decide to join Lisa's One Too Many program through me,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在正式开始之前，我想简单向大家介绍一个非常棒的免费大师班。本周一（3月3日）英国时间晚上8点，我的导师丽莎·约翰逊将举办这场活动。她将通过其强大的现金系统CASSH，带领我们了解为业务或生活增加经常性收入流所需的5个关键步骤。相信我，这真的非常实用。无论你是否参加了最近的挑战赛，本场分享会都包含了能改变游戏规则的深刻见解，帮助你迈向财务自由。此外，最后还有问答环节，如果你参加过挑战赛，还有机会赢得超级大奖。如果你决定通过我加入丽莎的“One Too Many”计划，
you will unlock some exclusive bonuses worth over £800, which includes one-to-one coaching, a three-session mastermind, accountability support, branding guidance and access to my masterclasses. Sports are limited, so grab yours now via my link tree, Dr. Mary Ann Trent, my social media, or just drop me a DM. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Do certain types of psychologists feel more drawn to private practice? And how does imposter syndrome
你将解锁价值超过800英镑的独家福利，包括一对一指导、三场大师班、问责支持、品牌指导以及我的大师班访问权限。名额有限，请立即通过我的Linktree、Dr. Mary Ann Trent、我的社交媒体或直接私信我来抢占名额。好了，让我们进入今天的节目。某些类型的心理学家是否对私人诊所更感兴趣？而冒名顶替综合症又是如何在迈出这一步的决定中
play into the decision to take the leap? In today's episode, I am joined by Dr. Rosie Gilderthorpe, and together we'll explore her journey from NHS into private practice, the kind of clinician she was, and the challenges and rewards of building a psychology business. Whether you're wondering what private practice is or curious about whether it could be a good step for you, stay tuned for insights that might just change your perspective. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne and it's my pleasure to be here for you as a qualified clinical psychologist. I say it's my pleasure to be here because of course being in private practice gives me more options to be able to choose
发挥作用的？在今天的节目中，我邀请到了罗西·吉尔德索普博士（Dr. Rosie Gilderthorpe），我们将共同探讨她从NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）转型到私营执业的心路历程、她曾是怎样的临床医生，以及建立心理学业务所面临的挑战与收获。无论你是对私人诊所感到好奇，还是想知道它是否适合你，请继续收听，这些见解可能会改变你的看法。嗨，欢迎收看《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是玛丽安博士，作为一名合格的临床心理学家，很高兴能在这里陪伴大家。我说很高兴能在这里，是因为在私人诊所工作确实让我有了更多自主选择权，
how I use my time. This is definitely something that gave me many headaches when I was in the NHS. I hope you'll find today's episode a really useful look into what private practice is and what fantastic opportunities it creates for you to be the kind of clinician you want to be and one that creates opportunities for services where you know there ought to be a better provision. If you do find this content helpful and you're watching on YouTube, please do like, please do subscribe, please do drop me a comment. Consider sharing it with people in
可以决定如何利用我的时间。这在我在NHS工作时确实让我头疼不已。希望今天的节目能让你对私人诊所有一个非常有价值的了解，看看它如何为你创造绝佳的机会，让你成为你想成为的那种临床医生，并为那些你知道本该提供更好服务的领域创造机会。如果你觉得这些内容很有帮助，并且正在YouTube上观看，请点赞、订阅并给我留言。也可以考虑把它分享给你
your network too. If you are listening as an MP3, please do share this episode, please do subscribe, follow the show and if you're on Spotify you can ask me questions on there too. And on Apple podcast please do rate and review. Hope you find this useful and I'll catch up with you on the other side. Hi, I just want to welcome along our guest for today Dr Rosie Gilderthorpe. Hi Rosie. Hello, it's lovely to be here. Thank you for having me on. Well thank you for being here and it was lovely to meet you in person recently as well which is where the idea for this episode came from. Yes you both got so
人脉圈里的人。如果你在听MP3音频，请分享这期节目，订阅并关注这个节目，如果你在Spotify上，也可以在上面向我提问。如果在Apple Podcasts上，请给出评分和评论。希望你觉得这期节目有用，我们稍后见。嗨，我只想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾罗西·吉尔德索普博士。嗨，罗西。你好，很高兴来到这里。谢谢你邀请我。不客气，很高兴最近能在线下见到你，这期节目的灵感也就是从那时产生的。是的，我们俩都有太多
much to say about private practice haven't we? We really have, we really have. So let's have a think just before we dive into that, just a little bit as a potted history really about your journey to becoming a clinical psychologist and to where you are now if that's okay. Yeah well I kind of hope that some of the aspiring psychologists listening to this might find it reassuring to know that when I was 21 and I graduated with an English degree I didn't even know what a psychologist did or what one was really. I had a sort of vague interest in psychology and how people worked but the reason I didn't study it at university was that I didn't
关于私人诊所的话题要聊，不是吗？确实如此，确实如此。所以在我们深入探讨之前，先简单回顾一下你成为临床心理学家的心路历程，以及走到今天这个位置的历史，如果可以的话。好的，我希望收听节目录音的那些有志于成为心理学家的年轻人能感到安心，因为当我21岁获得英语学位毕业时，我甚至不知道心理学家是做什么的，或者说心理学家到底是什么。我对心理学以及人们的工作方式有着一种模糊的兴趣，但我大学没有学这个的原因是，我当时认为
think there were jobs in it so I did English thinking I'd probably be a teacher or something like that then realized that I really didn't want to be a teacher and so started working in a gym mostly cleaning doing a bit of fitness instruction work that kind of thing. And then, because I am old, I saw an advert in the paper for a psych assistant job in the prison service. And I thought, oh, that'd be interesting getting to work in a prison and hear interesting stories that are different to mine. So I applied for it, not having a clue that psychology was this hyper competitive world
这方面没有什么工作机会，所以我学了英语，以为自己以后会当个老师什么的。后来我发现自己其实一点也不想当老师，于是开始在健身房工作，主要是打扫卫生，做点健身指导之类的工作。然后，因为我年纪不小了，我在报纸上看到了一则监狱服务部门心理学助理职位的招聘广告。我想，哦，在监狱里工作并听到与我不同的人生故事，这应该会很有趣。于是我申请了，完全不知道心理学是一个竞争异常激烈世界，
where everybody was like, you know, trying to take the best steps to get on the clinical course and been dreaming of it since they were 12. And I had no idea of any of that. I didn't know what CBT was. I just literally chanced my arm and went for an interview and they gave me the job, I think, as an experiment to see what would happen if they had somebody entirely mouldable. And so I did that job in the prison service for about four years in total and while I was there I studied for an open
每个人都在试图采取最佳步骤来进入临床培训课程，并且从12岁起就梦想着这件事。我对这一切一无所知。我甚至不知道什么是CBT（认知行为疗法）。我只是字面意义上凭运气去面试，然后他们把这份工作给了我，我想这大概是一个实验，想看看招一个完全可塑的人会发生什么。所以我在监狱服务部门总共做了大约四年这份工作，在那里工作期间，我攻读了开放大学的
university degree in psychology. I absolutely loved it. I loved every minute of that job and I probably would have stayed there if it hadn't been for the fact that they changed the route to chartership. So when I started in the prison service, it was the best employer in the whole wide world. They would pay for your masters and take you right the way through to chartership without you ever having to take a break from paid employment. And that was something that it just didn't feel like an option to me.
心理学学位。我真的很喜欢它。我喜欢那份工作的每一分钟，如果不是因为他们改变了获得特许资格的途径，我可能会一直留在那里。当我刚进监狱服务部门时，它是全世界最好的雇主。他们会支付你的硕士学费，并一直资助你获得特许资格，而你根本不需要中断带薪工作。这在当时对我来说似乎是一个不可能的选择。
I think there's so much interesting stuff we could go into around that, but essentially my parents are culturally working class, never found it acceptable, the idea of unpaid internships, that kind of thing for young people. It was, you're an adult, you stand on your own two feet, you pay your way. And so it never occurred to me to move back in with my parents or do any of those things, which I know now lots of people had
我认为围绕这一点有很多有趣的事情可以探讨，但本质上我的父母在文化上属于工人阶级，从来不接受无薪实习之类针对年轻人的想法。他们的观念是：你是成年人，你要靠自己的双脚站立，自食其力。因此我从来没想过搬回父母家住或者做类似的事情，而我知道现在很多人为了进入临床培训都不得不这样做。
to do to get onto clinical training. So I feel grateful that I managed to come through the route that I did. But that's why I was really attracted to the prison service, would have definitely stayed there. But when they changed the rules and you then had to go away and study on your own for a masters, I thought, my God, £3,000 for a masters? I'm not paying that. Which I'm laughing because it's so tragic that young people have to pay so much more than that now. But yes, so I at that point turned my attention to the NHS and the route into clinical training and again I knew nothing about it. I was really ignorant of the fact that it was really competitive and there were people kind of you know literally changing their whole lives to try and fit around this really narrow definition
所以对于能通过我走过的这条路走过来，我感到很感激。但这也是为什么我真的很被监狱服务部门吸引，如果可以的话我绝对会留在那里的原因。但当他们改变了规则，你必须离开并自己攻读硕士学位时，我心想：天哪，3000英镑读个硕士？我才不付这笔钱。现在笑是因为觉得太可悲了，年轻人现在要付的钱比这多得多。不过是的，当时我把注意力转向了NHS以及进入临床培训的途径，同样，我对它一无所知。我真的不知道它是如此竞争激烈，有那么多人为了适应这种非常狭隘的对临床心理学家应有形象的定义，
of what a clinical psychologist should look like. Thank God I didn't know any of that. But what I did know was that my open university qualification wasn't viewed in the same way that the red brick ones were. I'd heard that kind of on a grapevine from a friend. And so I applied to universities that did a test because I knew arrogantly that I would do well on a test and I did so that got me an interview at Salamands and I guess the rest is history but yeah I just wanted to share that because I think it seems for a lot of young people that I talk to now that they feel like if they don't follow this very rigid pathway that involves a lot of honoree, disgusting that they're called that in my view,
简直可以说是在彻底改变他们的整个生活。谢天我知道这些。但我知道的是，我的开放大学学历并不像红砖大学的学历那样受到认可。我从朋友那里听过这样的传言。所以我申请了那些有入学考试的大学，因为我很傲慢地知道自己考试成绩会很好，果真如此，这让我获得了莫兹利医院（Maudsley）的面试机会，我想剩下的就是历史了，但我只是想分享这一点，因为我觉得现在和我交流的很多年轻人似乎觉得，如果他们不遵循这条非常死板的路径——其中包含很多荣誉职位（在我看来，称它们为荣誉职位简直令人作呕），
posts where you don't get paid and you get treated really badly, they think you have to jump through every hoop perfectly and I didn't and I didn't even know about the hoops and I got there eventually so I just wanted to kind of share that bit of the story. Thank you, that is so important and I think you almost ended up as a forensic psychologist really. They would have been training you to be a forensic psychologist in the prison service I would assume. Yeah that's right and I would have loved it. I love clinical but I would have loved forensic as well, I think it's fascinating. Yeah, and I too miss the job papers because I think what I loved about the job papers is you didn't need to know search terms to search for. You could end up with something really interesting
也就是你拿不到薪水却受到很差对待的岗位——他们觉得你必须完美地跨过每一个栏杆。但我没有，我甚至不知道有这些栏杆，但我最终还是成功了，所以我只是想分享故事的这一部分。谢谢你，这太重要了。我想你最终几乎成了一名法医心理学家。我猜他们在监狱服务部门会把你培训成一名法医心理学家。是的，确实如此，我本来会很喜欢这个方向。我喜欢临床，但我也很喜欢法医，我认为它太迷人了。是的，我也怀念纸质招聘广告，因为我觉得纸质广告好在你不必知道要搜索什么关键词。你最终可能会发现一些真正点亮你、
that really lit you up, but you wouldn't necessarily have searched for. And I love that. But it's interesting that you were employed as a psychology assistant, because actually, of course, what we know is if it was called an assistant psychologist, you likely would have needed the BPS approved degree. But often psychology assistant jobs don't quite have the same person spec and essential criteria. Yeah, and it's really interesting, actually, because for that reason, they are not looked at in the same way on an application for clinical psychology, which is another reason that people, you know, I don't think my application would have got through if I hadn't gone for a course that did a test. But the experience that I got there was so much
但你未必会主动去搜索的有趣工作。我很喜欢这一点。但有趣的是，你当时是以心理学助理的身份受雇的，因为实际上，当然，我们知道如果职位名称是助理心理学家，你很可能需要BPS（英国心理学会）认证的学位。但通常心理学助理的工作并没有完全相同的岗位要求和基本标准。是的，这其实非常有趣，因为出于这个原因，在申请临床心理学时，它们的待遇并不一样，这也是为什么人们……我不认为如果我没有选择进行考试的课程，我的申请能通过。但在那里获得的经验比我通过助理心理学路线进来的很多同事要
richer than I think a lot of my colleagues that came through the assistant psychology route. So it really is about understanding what is relevant about the experience you've had. Like I was doing a PCLR interviews. I was doing a lot of cognitive testing, screening people for learning disabilities and just got really good at motivational interviewing, delivering CBT interventions, coaching as well. I did a lot of coaching in that role. And so what I think I was good at was extracting what I'd learnt and seeing
丰富得多。所以这其实在于理解你所拥有的经验中哪些是相关的。比如我当时在做PCLR（心理病态检查表修订版）访谈。我做了大量的认知测试，为有学习障碍的人进行筛查，并且擅长动机式访谈、提供CBT干预以及辅导。我在那个角色中做了很多辅导工作。所以我觉得自己擅长的是提取我学到的东西，并看出它们如何与临床心理学家的胜任特征相匹配，而这些特征我只是从BPS网站上获取的。而我认为很多人所做的是，他们有着如此多的冒名顶替综合症，以至于他们看不到自己可能不那么完美的经验如何实际上赋予了他们所寻找的一些胜任特征，因为他们太忙于告诉自己这并不完美。
how it would map onto the competencies for a clinical psychologist, which I just got off the BPS website. Whereas what I think a lot of people do is they have so much imposter syndrome that they don't see how their maybe not quite perfect experience might actually give them some of the competencies that they're looking for because they're so busy telling themselves it wasn't perfect. Whereas I think something I had as a young person was just this ability to go oh yeah well I think that sort of maps across and to communicate that hopefully quite well at interviews. So yeah, I think often you need more confidence in your experience than you might feel if you haven't come that traditional
然而，我认为我年轻时具备的一种能力就是这种想法：“哦，是的，我觉得这大致可以对应上，”并且希望能在面试中很好地表达这一点。所以，是的，如果你没有走那条传统的路线，你往往需要对自己的经验有更多信心。绝对的，根据我阅读的一些关于求职中性别差异的资料，数据表明，男性倾向于申请满足30%左右基本要求的职位，而女性只有在满足90%时才会申请。而你似乎采取了比许多人更全面的看法，而且这成功了，你看，你得到了那份工作。
route. Absolutely, I think from some of the kind of reading I've done into gender differences in job searches, the data suggested men will have a tendency of applying for jobs where they fulfill 30% or whatever of the essential criteria, whereas women would only apply when they kind of fulfill 90%. And it feels like you've kind of taken a more holistic view, actually, than many people would have done. And it worked, you know, because you got that job. Yeah, and it was partly. I think it would have been different, a different story if I'd really known how competitive it was. I'd never met a clinical psychologist when I went to
是的，部分原因是这样的。如果我当时真的知道竞争有多激烈，那就会是另一个故事了。我去莫兹利面试时，甚至从未见过临床心理学家。所以没有人告诉我这是个残酷的竞争，也没有人告诉我人们可能会申请10年之久。当我到了那里，看到那些人，这成了他们的一切时，（你知道，）这确实震动了我。我想如果我在面试前就见过他们，我可能无法通过。但我凭借对这一切的一无所知顺利过关了。然后它在培训的第一天就像大锤一样向我袭来。我只是觉得我不配呆在这里。
Salomon. So there was nobody to tell me that it was really cutthroat and that people would have been applying for like 10 years. And when I got there, and I saw those people, and it was everything to them, you know, that shook me a bit. And I think if I'd met them before I'd done the interview, I probably wouldn't have gotten through it. But I kind of sailed through with a bit of ignorance about all of that. And then it hit me like a sledgehammer on day one of training. And I just thought I don't deserve to be here.
从那以后事情就变得很棘手了。但幸运的是，我生活中的没有人知道临床心理学是一件大事。你知道我的父母，我爸爸对我说“他们会付钱让你做这个？”，我说“是的”。所以，在我到达那里之前，没有人给我灌输过这是一件大事的概念。是的，有时这会有所帮助，不过我想我的下一个问题是，当你开始培训时感觉如何，听起来这是一个非常陡峭的学习曲线。
And it was tricky after that point. But thankfully, no one in my life knew that clinical psychology was a big deal. You know my parents, my dad said to me what they'll pay you to do that and I was like yeah. So yeah nobody had really got in my head about it being a massive deal before I got there. Yeah well sometimes that helps but yeah I guess my next question was going to be what was it like when you started training, but it sounds like it was a very steep learning curve.
哦，非常陡峭，因为监狱服务部门的文化与临床心理学的文化有着天壤之别。而且，你知道，我们今天可能会聊到临床心理学文化中的一些问题，但你知道，这两者都不是健康或有用文化的完美代表。不过，监狱服务部门的文化非常直率。他们非常怀疑那些使用过度委婉、甚至可能过于富有同情心语言的人。而当我降落在莫兹利时，我很快就领悟到了。我心想：“哦，好吧，在我们在这里表达观点之前，我们必须说一千遍‘我觉得’。”我简直不敢相信大家说话兜了那么多圈子。但我还是学会了，并且学会了如何适应新文化。
Oh, hugely, because the culture in the prison service could not be more different to the culture of clinical psychology. And, you know, we'll probably talk a bit today about the problems in the culture of clinical psychology, but you know, neither of them are, you know, a perfect example of a healthy or a useful culture by a long stretch. But the culture in the prison service was very straight talking. They were very suspicious of people that used overly tentative and perhaps overly compassionate language. Whereas I landed in Salamand and picked up very quickly. I was like, oh, okay, we have to say I'm wandering a thousand times before we're allowed to make a point here. And I just couldn't believe the amount of circles that people talked in. But I picked
而且我看到了两者的好处。你知道，我永远不想让人觉得我认为一个比另一个更好，其实我真的不这么认为。我认为在心理学的两个领域中，我们需要找到一个中间立场。是的，这是一个非常陡峭的学习曲线。而且我也觉得有很多——我们今天肯定会深入讨论这一点——很多人觉得能呆在那里有一种负罪感，觉得自己拿了很多钱去做一份并不配拿到这么多钱的工作。在较低层级上，监狱服务部门的薪水比NHS少得多。所以当我做心理学助理时，我们的年薪实际上大约是14,000英镑。
it up and I learned how to adapt to the new culture. And I see the benefits of both. You know, I never want to sound like I think one is better than the other, I actually don't. I think in both streams of psychology, we need to find a middle ground. Yeah, it was a very steep learning curve. And I think also there was a lot of, and we're going to talk loads about this today, I'm sure, but a lot of people felt kind of guilty to be there
几年后，我们通过打官司把薪水提高到了大约17,000英镑，但起薪真的非常非常低，而我们NHS的同行总是拿稍微多一点的薪水。但我一直都看到了这种不公。从第一天起我就觉得：考虑到我们在这里做的事情，这是一份低薪工作，在监狱服务部门尤其鲜明，因为你会看到没有学历的男性同事第一天上班赚得比你还多，做的是主要涉及搬运重物甚至不需要接触囚犯的工作。
and like they were being paid loads for something that they didn't deserve to be paid loads for. And the prison service pays a lot less than the NHS in the lower level. So when I was a psychological assistant, we were actually being paid, I think, £14,000 a year. We then, a couple of years in, won a court case to get that raised up to about £17,000, I think £14,000 a year. We then a couple of years in won a court case to get that raised up to about £17,000 I think, but it was very very low paid and our NHS equivalents were always on a little bit more. But I'd always seen the injustice in it. I'd always from day one been like this is a low paid job considering what we're doing here and in the prison service it's really stark
而我们作为角色的一部分，要与囚犯进行无监督的接触，这也是为什么我们最终赢得那场官司的原因。但我从来没有认为我们拿的钱太多了，从来没有。而我一进入临床心理学培训，每个人都在谈论我们薪水过高。说实话，我真的无法理解这一点。而且当时缺乏的是对你为什么会有这种感觉的反思。我当时觉得，而且现在依然觉得，这源于创伤。我觉得这些人被洗脑了，让他们相信自己一文不值。我认为这来自于连续四五次申请一份你很擅长的工作却被拒绝。我认为这在心理上对你没有好处。而且我认为连续四五次去
because you would have male colleagues with no qualifications coming in on day one earning more than you in a job which was mostly sort of manual handling and not even people that had contact with prisoners. Whereas we would have, you know, unsupervised contact with prisoners as part of our role, which is, yeah, why we won that court case eventually. But I'd never considered that we were overpaid, ever. And I landed in clinical psychology training and everyone's talking about us being overpaid. And I couldn't, I really couldn't wrap my head around it, to be honest. And what there wasn't much recognition of was reflection on why you would feel that way. And I felt at the time,
做一份困难的工作却完全没有薪水，就像我们在荣誉心理学职位上所做的那样，我认为这
and I still feel that it came from trauma. I felt these people have had their brains washed into believing that they're not worth anything. And I think that comes from applying for a job that you're good for, you know, five times before they let you do it. I don't think that's good for you psychologically. And I don't think going, you know, five times before they let you do it. I don't think that's good for you psychologically. And I don't think going, you know, doing a difficult job and not being paid at all for it, as we do in the honorary psych jobs, I don't think that
对你没有好处。我认为这会给你留下一种印象，即你不配过上舒适的生活，基本上就是舒适的生活，我觉得这真的很可悲。嗯，完全同意。我们曾有一整期节目讨论荣誉助理心理学家岗位的伦理问题，是的，正如你所说，人们开始认为：“嗯，我不能申请那些正式编制的职位，因为我做的事不够好。”实际上，是的，你做得够好，因为实际上，他们本该把那个职位公开招聘为正式岗位，因为没有你，他们根本无法运行那个治疗小组。
that's good for you. I think it leaves you with this idea that you're not worthy of having a comfortable life, you know, basically comfortable life, which I think is really sad. Mm, totally agree. We've had a whole episode on the ethics of honorary assistant psychologist posts, and yeah, like you say, like people begin to think, well, I can't apply for something qualified because I wouldn't, I'm not, I'm not doing good enough stuff here. It's actually, yes, you are, because actually, they ought to have advertised that as a substantive post because they cannot run that therapy group without you.
如果没有你作为额外的比例人数，他们就无法进行那些神经心理学评估。你是劳动力中不可或缺的一部分，这很不公平。所以拜托，如果有人对此感兴趣，请务必收听关于荣誉心理学职位的这期节目。但听起来你有着非常广泛的经验，自然而然地，你也非常善于反思，自从接近具备正式资格以来，你一直在磨练自己的技能，而且你获得资格已经有一段时间了。罗西，你认为拥有这种广泛的经验是否有助于你顺利转型进入私人诊所？
They can't do those, you know, those neuro-psychs without you being the extra ratio of numbers. You are an essential part of the workforce, so it's not fair. So please, if anyone's interested in that, please do check out the episode on honorees psychs. But so it sounds like you are really broadly experienced and naturally, of course, very reflective, but you've honed your craft since kind of becoming closer to qualified and you've
是的，去私人诊所从来都不是我的初衷，这很有趣，因为我觉得自己其实挺有创业精神的，但在年轻时我并没有认清这一点。私人诊所最终成为我能够继续从事心理学家工作的唯一途径。我的孩子有特殊需求，我们是一个军人家庭，因此随着不断的搬迁、缺乏支持网络，加上我的孩子们无法真正应付诸如托儿所之类的事情，
been qualified for some time now. Do you think having that broad experience helped you to springboard into private practice, Rosie? Yes, it was never really my intention to go into private practice, which is interesting because I think I am quite entrepreneurial but I didn't recognise that in myself as a younger person. Private practice became the only route available to me to continue being a psychologist. My kids have additional needs, we're a military family, and so with all the moving and lack of support network and the fact that my children couldn't really manage things like nursery,
我根本无法继续在NHS工作。但我们需要我的收入，所以我不想从事其他任何工作。你知道，我很热爱心理学，尽管我没有像很多人那样有长期的职业规划。当我进入这个领域时，我真的觉得它满足了我所有的需求。我喜欢学术方面。我喜欢应用部分。我喜欢和一个房间里的人在一起。
it just wasn't possible for me to continue in the NHS. But we needed my income, and so I didn't want to work as anything else. You know, I really love psychology, much as I didn't have a long-term game plan like a lot of people do. When I arrived in it, I really felt it ticked all of my boxes. I love the academic side. I love the applied bit. I love being in a room with people.
我只是喜欢关于它的一切。所以我想：“好吧，我必须找到一种成为心理学家的方法，它不需要我每天从8点到4点或9点到5点呆在离家很远的办公室里。”所以私人诊所有效地成为了我唯一的选择。而且我认为，拥有略微不同的私人诊所转型之旅确实对我有所帮助，因为这意味着我习惯于广泛思考如何运用心理学，并寻找不同的机会来运用我的技能。
I just love everything about it. So I was like, right, OK, I'm going gonna have to find a way to be a psychologist that doesn't require me to be in an office far away from my home from like eight till four or nine till five every day. And so private practice was the only option for me really. And I think it did help that I'd had a, you know, slightly different journey into private practice, because I suppose it meant that I'd been used to thinking quite widely about how psychology can be used and looking for different opportunities to use my skills.
但我也认为临床心理学培训本身就赋予了我们这一点。我认为你接受的是广泛的培训，这真的非常非常有用。有时我觉得我们低估了这一点。我刚结束培训时心想：“天哪，我是个万金油，什么都会但什么都不精。”所有那些冒名顶替的想法都涌上心头。但实际上，当你在私人诊所里遇到一个有着复杂人生经历的客户，并且你意识到：天哪，你在这次评估会谈中提到的某件事触及了
But I also think clinical psychology training does give us that anyway. I think you have a broad training, which is really, really useful to you. And sometimes I think we underestimate that. I came out of training thinking like, oh my God, I'm a jack of all trades and a master of none. Like all of those imposter thoughts really came up. But actually, when you kind of find yourself with a client in private practice that has a complicated life history and you realize gosh you've mentioned something in this assessment session which touches
你在培训各个阶段的经验，那时你就会意识到这是一笔巨大的财富，因为你的案例构想因此变得更加丰富。而且我发现，而且现在依然发现，我一直在使用我的法医培训。它会出现在非常意想不到的场景中。它绝对为我的博士研究打下了基础，因为在监狱服务部门的那段时间里，我一定做过数百次学习障碍筛查，远超过我能数清的次数。所以当需要学习如何进行全面的神经发育评估时，我已经对所有这些事情充满信心了，这其实挺棘手的，比如倒背数字和积木设计，
on my experience from every part of training then you realize what an asset that is because your formulations are that much richer for it but I did find and I still find that I use my forensic training all the time. It comes up in really unusual settings. And it definitely springboarded my doctoral research because in my time in the prison service I must have done hundreds, like way more than I'd ever be able to account of learning disability screenings. And so when it came to learning how to do a full-scale neurodevelopmental assessment, I was already confident with all that stuff, which is quite tricky, like reversing and block design,
这些都违背了我天生擅长的东西。我当时不需要学习所有那些基础知识，我真正学习的是解读的细微差别。所以，是的，我认为这种更广泛的基础极大地帮助我度过了培训期，并进入了正式的工作中。但奇怪的是，当我进入私人诊所时，我的视野依然有点狭隘。我真的会鼓励任何考虑进入私人诊所的人认识到，你可以独立从事任何专业领域。你有不同的营销方法和不同的商业模式，所有这些都是可能的。然而当我刚开始独立执业时，我没有什么可以请教的榜样，
which goes against everything that I am naturally good at. I didn't have to learn all of that at that point. I just really was learning the nuance of interpretation. So yeah, I think it helped me immensely through training and then going into qualified work, that I'd had that foundation which was a bit broader. But weirdly, when I went into private practice, I was still a little bit narrow about it. And I'd really encourage anybody that's thinking about going to private practice to recognize that you can do any specialism independently. You have different methods of marketing and you have a different business model but all of them are possible whereas when I went into independent practice I didn't have like role models that I could ask I
我真的不认识任何在我之前这样做过的人，除非是那些超级资深的人，而那些资深人士的客户会自动找上门，因为那个地区的所有人都已经认识他们了。所以没有一个像我这样走过这条路的人是我所知道其故事的。因此，我放弃了我在第一份合格工作中所从事的学习障碍专业，转入了围产期心理健康领域，部分原因是我不知道学习障碍工作在私人诊所里该如何运作。而且也是因为我在怀孕期间有过一段糟糕的妊娠剧吐（hyperemesis gravidarum）个人经历，却找不到任何心理支持。所以我有（你知道的）一腔热情。
didn't really know anybody that had done it before me who wasn't mega super experienced and so clients just came to them because everybody in that area already knew who they were. So there was nobody like me who had done it that I knew the story of. So I stepped away from my specialism in learning disability, which is what I was doing in my first qualified job, and went into perinatal, partially because I didn't know how learning disability work would work in private practice. And also because I'd had a terrible personal experience of hyper-emesis gravadarum in pregnancy, and hadn't been able to find any psychological support. So I had, you know, I was passionate about it. And
我真的很高兴自己走了这条路。但我也意识到，我有比自己意识到的更多的选择。我想让任何其他考虑自己职业生涯和私人工作的人知道，你可以做到这一点，你可以让任何专业领域发挥作用。抱歉，不，没关系。我想，从结识其他私人心理学家那里我真正学到的是，当我们自己经历过类似的经历时，许多人确实开始真正找到自己的热情所在，
I'm really glad that I did go that route. But I'm also aware that I had more options available to me than I realized. And I'd like anybody else, you know, thinking about their career and their private work to know you can do that you can make any specialism work. Sorry, No, that's okay. I think, I think what I've learned really from getting to know other private psychologists is many of us do start to really find our passion when we've had some similar life experience to that ourselves
因为正如你所说，你开始注意到其中的差距。所以当我的父亲去世，以及我带着周围人对悲伤一无所知的感觉去面对这个世界时，我开始谈论悲伤。是的，显而易见，从你的经历中，以及卡拉·戴维博士（Dr. Cara Davey）的经历中——她不幸经历了女儿的悲伤死产，现在也真正支持着这方面的人。然后，你知道，我只是觉得，就像他们说的，你不需要被公共汽车撞到才知道痛，但它确实对你的同理心大有帮助。我也这么认为。而且也知道人们到底需要什么。
because you begin, like you say, to notice the gaps in that. So I started to begin to speak about grief when my dad died and my experience of kind of navigate the world with people being really, really rubbish at talking about grief. And yeah, and obviously what we know from your experiences and then Dr. Cara Davey as well who unfortunately experienced a very sad sterile birth of her daughter and now really supports people in that as well. And then, you know, I just think it really, you don't have to be hit by a bus as they say to know it hurts, but it sure does help with your empathy. I think so. And I think knowing what people actually need as
我喜欢独立工作的一点是，你可以看到服务中的空白并设计填补空白的东西。这并不总是心理治疗。有时是的。你知道，对于妊娠剧吐，我知道有一些非常有效的疗法可以真正帮助人们，但这些并不是常规提供的。在NHS中，围产期心理学家问我什么是妊娠剧吐也并非闻所未闻，这本该是令人震惊的。这对我来说真的很吓人，因为它影响了百分之二到百分之三的孕妇。这是最低的
well. And what I love about independent work is that you can see a gap in provision and design something that fills it. And that's not always therapy. Sometimes it is. And you know, for hyperemesis, I know that there are very effective therapies that can really help people but those are not routinely offered. In the NHS it's not unheard of for even a perinatal psychologist to ask me what is hyperemesis gravidarum which should be shocking. It is really scary to me because it affects two to three percent of pregnancies. That's the lowest
估计。比例甚至可能高达百分之十，然而（你知道的）这种知识并不普及，这些人（你知道的）迫切需要支持。我认为经历妊娠剧吐是不可能的——对于任何不知道的人来说，它是严重、完全严重且完全无法缓解的恶心，通常还伴有呕吐，发生在怀孕期间恶心和呕吐典型窗口期之外。所以我对它的定义，我也鼓励任何人这样定义的标准是：如果它干扰了你过上美好的生活，比如你无法去上班、无法社交、无法做那些让你的生活值得过下去的事情，那么这就是HG（妊娠剧吐）。
estimate. It could be as much as 10 percent and yet you know the knowledge is not really there that these people are you know in desperate need of support. I believe it's impossible to experience hyperemesis gravadarum which for anybody that doesn't know it's severe completely severe, completely intractable nausea and usually vomiting as well that occurs you know outside of the typical window for nausea and vomiting in pregnancy. So the way that I define it and I'd encourage anybody to define it is that if it's interfering with you living a good life so you can't go to work, you can't socialize, you can't do the things that make your life worth living, then it's HG.
去寻求帮助吧。因为怀孕期间正常的恶心和呕吐，你应该能够围绕它正常生活。而HG患者则不能。这就好比你失去了所有良好心理健康的基石。我认为最高调的案例之一是凯特王妃（Princess Catherine，剑桥公国夫人）。
Get help for it. Because normal nausea and vomiting in pregnancy, you should be able to live your life around it. Whereas people with HG can't. It's like you lose all of those building blocks of good mental wellbeing. I think one of the most high profile cases was Princess Catherine, Duchess of Cambridge.
她怀乔治的时候得了这个病，对吧？所以这引发了更多的对话，并且可能、希望能够持续下去。曾经是，又曾经不是，对吧？是的，是也不是。所以是的，但很明显她接受了私人医疗保健，并且得到了非常迅速的治疗。这就像一个奇怪的先有鸡还是先有蛋的情景。
She had it with George, I think, didn't she? And so that kind of started more of a conversation and then has maybe, hopefully stuck. Did and didn't, no? Yeah, it did and it didn't. So it did, but obviously she accesses private healthcare and will have received treatment extremely promptly. And it's like a weird chicken and egg scenario.
所以我诊所里的许多人都会说：“哦，好吧，我得的可能不是HG，因为我从来没有挂过盐水。我从来没有接受过（你知道的）维生素注射或凯特王妃接受过的任何治疗。所以我的情况肯定没那么糟糕。”不，恐慌的是，这个国家针对HG的医疗护理真的很糟糕。我刚刚在我的播客《Pregnant and Sick》中录制了一集，嘉宾是一位专攻剧吐的医生。我们在这里没有得到我们需要的帮助。我们没有得到我们需要的药物。我们没有得到我们需要的营养。我们没有得到我们需要的帮助。我们没有得到我们需要的药物。我们没有得到我们需要的营养。
So I speak to many people in my clinic that say, oh, well, mine wasn't maybe mine wasn't HG because I never had a drip. I never had, you know, vitamin injections or any of the stuff that Princess Catherine had. So mine must have not been as bad. No, I'm afraid care in this country is just really poor for HG. I've just recorded an episode of my podcast, Pregnant and Sick, with a doctor who specialises in hyperemesis. And we don't get the help that we need here. We don't get the drugs that we need. We don't get the nutrition that we need. We don't get the help that we need here. We don't get the drugs that we need. We don't get the nutrition that we need.
我们需要时没有得到静脉输液。这意味着我们的预后要糟糕得多。所以人们用自己没有得到帮助这一事实来告诉自己，他们的病情并不严重，而实际上，不幸的是，在这个国家你可能会患非常严重的HG，却得不到任何帮助，除非你知道该要求什么。
We don't get IV drip when we need it. And that means that we have much worse outcomes. So people are using the fact that they didn't get help to tell themselves that their condition was not severe, when actually, unfortunately, you can have very severe HG in this country and not receive any help for it unless you know what to ask for.
所以我在Substack上所做的大部分工作，都是谈论你可以要求什么、你应该倡导什么，以及它如何能帮助你的原因。因此，显而易见，在心理学方面，我们有来自接纳承诺疗法（ACT）文献的所有内容，这对于管理症状并在心理上度过难关非常有帮助。我们还可以看到，EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工疗法）对很多人都很有帮助，我在诊所里经常使用它。对于管理创伤真的非常非常有帮助，同时也能打破那些让你一直呕吐的条件反射。所以这会非常有用。
So a lot of what I do on Substack is talk about what you can ask for and what you should be advocating for and the reasons that it can help you as well. So obviously on the psychological side, we've got all the stuff from the acceptance and commitment therapy literature, which is really helpful for managing symptoms and helping you to get through it psychologically. We can also see that EMDR is quite helpful for lots of people and I use that a lot in my clinic. Really, really helpful for managing the trauma but also for breaking some of those associations that make you just vomit all the time. So that can be really useful.
但除此之外，还有大量的药物、大量安全的医疗选择，你可以去要求并尝试，而这些通常不会主动提供给人们。营养支持应该在大多数人实际得到它的很久之前就提供。但同样，如果你去要求，你可以被转诊到专业服务机构，所以一定要去问。不过总之，正如你所说，玛丽安，这些信息没有公之于众，也没有社交媒体账号向人们提供这些信息，这让我简直快疯了，但（你知道的）人们经历这一切甚至不寻求治疗，因为他们不知道这可以帮助他们。所以我从独立执业的第一天起，
But also there's a ton of medications, loads of medical options that are safe that you can ask for and try and they don't normally get offered to people. And nutritional support should be available way before it is to most people. But again if you ask, there are specialist services you can be referred to so always ask. But anyway as you can tell Marianne it absolutely drove me bonkers that this information wasn't out there for people and that there weren't social media accounts giving people this information but you know people go through this and they don't even look for therapy because they don't know that it can help them. So I set out
就大声宣扬妊娠剧吐以及治疗能够带来帮助的事实，直到现在我依然在大声呼吁，而且我觉得我们正在取得一些进展。有一个了不起的慈善机构——“妊娠恶心支持”（Pregnancy Sickness Support），他们发布了一些非常好的内容，并产生了一些轰动。但回到为什么独立工作如此重要这个问题上，就是为了这个原因。因为如果你在NHS没有被委任去谈论妊娠剧吐，你就不能谈。如果他们还没有认识到这是一个问题，你就不能研究它，你不能因此去看患者，你不能用它做任何事情，
early doors to shout about hyperemesis gravidarum and the fact that therapy helps from day one of my independent practice and I'm still shouting about it a lot now and I do feel we're getting somewhere. There's an amazing charity, Pregnancy Sickness Support, who have put some really good stuff out there and it's making a bit of a splash. But to come back to why is independent work so important, it's for this reason. Because if you're not commissioned to talk about hyperemesis gravidarum in the NHS, you can't do it. And if they haven't yet recognised that this is a problem, you can't research it, you can't see patients for it, you can't do anything
你不能公开表达关于它的意见。而因为我是独立的，我正在这个领域进行研究，我正在这个领域写作，我在社交媒体上，在Substack上，我正在为患有这种病症的客户提供面诊。我不知道，但我认为如果我在围产期服务部门工作，我将无法接待大多数来找我的人，因为他们已经被那些更容易符合其标准的人压垮了。所以，是的，这有点像是一番抱怨，但我确实热爱独立工作，因为你可以追求自己的兴趣。
with it, you can't put your opinions out publicly about it. Whereas because I'm independent, I'm working on research in this area, I'm writing on this area, I'm on social media, I'm on Substack, and I'm seeing clients for this condition. And I don't know, but I don't think I'd be able to see most of the people that come to me if I was working in a perinatal service, because they are so overwhelmed with the people that more easily meet their criteria. So yeah, it's a bit of a rant, but I do love working independently because you get to pursue your interests.
而且你不仅仅是开设了一家私人诊所，你还决定帮助支持其他人开设他们自己的私人诊所。这里面有很多羞耻感，不是吗？比如：“我该不该去？”“别人会怎么说？”“如果我由NHS培养却选择离开，这说明了什么？”在我们在私人诊所接待第一位客户之前，有大量的障碍需要克服，对吧？哦，百分之百。而且，正如我之前提到的，我对此并没有太多选择。所以我真的感受到了这种羞耻感的重量。我（你知道的）真的很挣扎。我并不
And you didn't just start a private practice, you decided you were going to help support others to start their private practice as well. And there's a lot of shame out there, isn't there, about should I? Shouldn't I? What would other people say? You know, what does it say about me if I've been trained by the NHS to then leave? There's a load of hurdles to overcome before we even begin to see our first client in private practice, isn't there? Oh, 100%. And, you know, as I've already mentioned, I didn't have a very much choice about it. So I really I felt the weight of that shame. I, you know, I really struggled. I didn't
想去开私人诊所。在我接受培训的莫兹利，关于私人诊所的论述极其负面。我从未想过自己会开诊所，直到可能我快到50多岁的时候。我想我曾有过一个小小的愿景，即我可能会在某个阶段退休后进入私人诊所，但它并不是我游戏计划的一部分。所以，是的，我经历了所有的强烈情绪，但归根结底，我的孩子们需要支持。所以我克服了这些强烈的情感，让它成为了现实。这极其痛苦。我的意思是，我整整一年每天都胃痛。在那整整一年里，我因为这件事感到非常难过。
want to go into private practice. At Salamans, where I trained, the discourse around private practice was extremely negative. I hadn't imagined it for myself until maybe I was in my late 50s or something. I think I'd had a little vision that I might retire into private practice at some stage, but it hadn't been part of the game plan for me. And so, yeah, I had all of the big feelings, but at the end of the day, my children needed something. And so I fought through the big feelings and made it happen. And it was extremely painful. I mean, I literally had an upset stomach every day for a year. I felt so ill about it for that whole year.
人们经常问我为什么这么自信，或者我是怎么觉得做业务和营销这么容易的。我在第一年的时候一点也没有这种感觉。但对我来说发生的事情，我相信也是对大多数人发生的事情，就是你开始帮助别人，你开始帮助那些无法从NHS获得帮助的人。
People often ask me like how I'm so confident or how I find it so easy to do business and marketing. I did not find it like that in the first year at all. But what happened for me, and I believe what happened to most people is you start to help people and you start to help people that weren't getting help from the NHS.
可悲的是，有太多这样的人，（你知道的）当你真正在NHS工作时，你会想象使用私人服务的人都拥有特权，他们其实不需要太多帮助。事实并非如此。我发现社会的巨大群体因为这样或那样的原因不符合标准，从而被拒绝提供服务。所以自第一年以来，我再也没有感到过内疚，因为我看到了自己正在做的工作是这些人无法通过其他途径获得的。我也发现有许多不同的商业模式和许多回馈那些付不起全额费用的人的方法。所以我在心理学商业学校里经常谈论永远不要对费用打折。
And sadly, that's an awful lot of people who, you know, you imagine when you're working in the NHS, you imagine the people using private services are all mega privileged and they don't really need very much. That is not the case. I found there were just huge sections of society that weren't meeting criteria for one reason or another and were being refused a service. And so I've never felt guilty really since that first year because I can see the work that I'm doing that these people can't get any other way. I've also found there are loads of different business models and loads of ways of giving back to people that can't afford your full fee. So I talk a lot in psychology business school about never discounting your fees.
可悲的是，有相当多的人——你知道的，当你在NHS工作时，你会想象使用私立服务的人都是超级特权阶层，他们其实并不太需要什么帮助。事实并非如此。我发现社会上有很大一部分人由于某种原因不符合标准而被拒绝提供服务。因此，自从第一年以来，我从未真正感到内疚，因为我能看到我所做的工作是这些人无法通过其他任何途径获得的。我还发现有许多不同的商业模式，以及很多回馈那些承担不起你全部费用的人的方法。因此，我在心理学商业学校里经常谈到永远不要对你的费用打折。
You work out what your fee needs to be and you charge that fee because otherwise you're going to end up working for less than you did in the NHS very quickly. You know, if you've never worked privately, you won't believe me, but you just have to trust me on this one. I've supported hundreds of people through this process and you can very easily end up on minimum wage quickly if you start discounting your services. So you leave that fee where it needs to be and then you get creative about the other ways that you can give back. So the simplest way is you offer some pro bono hours through a charity. I've done that from very early on in my practice. But you can do other things like you can work on research, it doesn't necessarily have funding behind it yet. You can join in with projects that local community interest
你得算出你的收费应该是多少，然后就按这个标准收费，因为否则你很快就会落得个收入比在英国国民保健制度（NHS）工作时还要低的下场。你知道，如果你从来没有做过私人执业，你不会相信我的话，但在这件事上你必须相信我。我通过这个过程支持过成百上千的人，如果你开始对服务进行打折，你很容易就会迅速沦落到拿最低工资的地步。所以，你要把收费维持在应有的水平，然后通过其他可以回馈社会的方式发挥创意。最简单的方法是通过慈善机构提供一些义工服务。我从开业之初就开始这样做了。但你还可以做其他事情，比如你可以参与研究，虽然它背后不一定有资金支持。你可以加入当地社区利益
companies are running. You can provide supervision that people can't afford to pay for for their charity or their CIC. You can set up your own CIC. I ran one for a few years alongside my private practice. And so there's tons of things that you can do to give back and provide something again that is not being provided. And that independence allows you to be really creative about how you do that. Yeah, I think the guilt and the shame kind of lifted when I discovered all those different ways of working. And I realized I was making a really positive impact in people's lives. But it was very big for me at the beginning. So yeah, I don't want people to think that it's just a mindset
公司正在运营的项目。你可以为那些无力支付费用的慈善机构或社区利益公司（CIC）提供他们付不起钱的督导服务。你可以建立你自己的社区利益公司。我在私人执业的同时经营过几年这样的机构。所以，有很多事情可以用来回馈社会，再次提供一些没有得到满足的服务。这种独立性让你在如何做到这一点上非常有创造力。是的，当我发现所有这些不同的工作方式时，内疚感和羞耻感似乎减轻了。我意识到我在人们的生活中产生了非常积极的影响。但这对我刚开始的时候来说意义重大。所以，是的，我不想让人们认为这只是一种心态
that you can switch on and off. I don't think it is for a lot of us. You have to get out there and start doing it and then your feelings will start changing as a result of your actions rather than, you know, for me anyway, I couldn't do it as a thought experiment really. But yeah, so you asked why I set up psychology business school to support other people. And that was because two years into my practice, I'd found my feet with it. I wasn't feeling sick anymore. I'd found these other business models which had made my income a lot more stable. I'd kind of worked my way through a lot of that shame and a lot of those problems.
你可以随心所欲地开启或关闭它。对于我们许多人来说，我不认为它是这样的。你必须走出去并开始去做，然后你的感受就会因为你的行动而开始改变，而不是——你知道的，对我和说 anyway——我真的无法把它当作一个思想实验来做。但是，是的，所以你问我为什么要建立心理学商业学校来支持其他人。那是因为在我开业两年后，我已经站稳脚跟了。我不再感到恶心了。我找到了其他让我的收入稳定得多的商业模式。我已经通过很多那样的羞耻感和许多那样的问题找到了出路。
And I looked around me and there really wasn't anybody teaching about private practice out there. There was one good book that I found the Rob Bore book and that had been really helpful to me, but I'd spent hours at the beginning Googling. How do I set up a psychology private practice? How do I do a good private practice? And I'm a clinical psychologist. Like all those things I put into Google had never returned any UK-based results and I didn't find the US results
当我环顾四周时，发现真的没有人真正在外面教导关于私人执业的知识。我找到了一本好书，也就是罗布·博尔（Rob Bore）的书，那对我真的很有帮助，但在开始的时候，我在谷歌上花了几个小时搜索。我该如何建立一个心理学私人诊所？我该如何经营一个好的私人诊所？而我是一名临床心理学家。就像我输入谷歌的所有那些事情一样，从来没有返回过任何基于英国的结果，而且我也没有找到美国的那些结果
very helpful because it's such a different system over there. And so when I started to kind of feel a bit more confident and I met a couple of other psychologists in Plymouth who were really supportive of me and made me feel a bit more confident about myself. I thought well let's put a podcast together where I get people that have done well in private practice to come on and talk to me about the exciting stuff they do and just get some positive narratives out there that private practice can be inspiring and exciting and it doesn't have to be shameful and then we can infuse that with some tips and tricks for people as well, so they at least know how to get their foundation sorted
非常有用，因为那里的系统太不相同了。所以当我开始感到更有自信一点时，我在普利茅斯遇到了另外几位心理学家，他们非常支持我，让我对自己的信心增加了一些。我想，好吧，让我们做一个播客，邀请那些在私人执业中做得很好的人来跟我聊聊他们所做的令人兴奋的事情，并把一些积极的叙事传播出去，即私人执业可以鼓舞人心且令人兴奋，它不必是令人羞耻的，然后我们可以向其中注入一些给人们的小贴士和技巧，这样他们至少知道如何理顺他们的基础
and just feel a bit less alone with it. So that was the intention of the Business of Psychology podcast, which is still going now, I'm proud to say. But very quickly people started to ask me for specific stuff. And so I'd get experts in to do a masterclass on things like, should I be a limited
并且对它感到稍微不那么孤单。这就是“心理学商业”播客（The Business of Psychology podcast）的初衷，我很自豪地说，它现在仍在继续。但很快人们就开始向我索要具体的内容了。因此，我会请专家来就诸如“我应该注册成为有限公司吗？”之类的事情开设大师班
company? And those kinds of common questions that come up at the beginning. And yeah, before I knew it really, that had spiralled into a course, and then coaching. And yeah, it's just gone from there, really. And I love it. I love any part I can play in getting more independent work out there so that we can start evidencing the gaps that exist in public sector. I, yeah, I'm so excited about that. I love every one of my coaching clients inspires me and every single one of them is meeting a need
以及那些在开始时常常见到的问题。是的，在我真正意识到之前，那已经演变成了一门课程，然后是教练辅导。是的，它真的就从那里发展开来了。我爱极了。我喜欢我在其中发挥的任何作用，以便将更多独立的工作推向公众，这样我们就可以开始证明公共部门中存在的差距。我，是的，对此我感到非常兴奋。我热爱我的每一位教练辅导客户，他们都激励着我，他们每个人都在满足
that the public sector doesn't meet. And if we all collect our evidence, we can show what needs are not being met and advocate for those people to the public sector. And ultimately, that is my goal. Oh, that is so powerful. And yeah, that's your that's your why. But it sounds like we're kind of quite similar in that we like we like to spread our time over a kind of variety of things in the week and across the month. Yeah, it sounds like you've got two podcasts on the go.
公共部门无法满足的需求。如果我们所有人都能收集证据，我们就能展示哪些需求没有得到满足，并为这些人向公共部门进行倡导。归根结底，这就是我的目标。哦，那太有力量了。是的，那是你的“初心”。但听起来我们俩挺相似的，我们都喜欢把时间分散在一周和一整月的各种不同事情上。是的，听起来你同时在做两个播客。
Yeah. Is that right? Well, hats off to you. One is a lot to manage, I find. So, Pregnant and Sick is a bit different. So, I set that up a couple of years ago and I use it basically as a like resource for people who are going through hyperemesis or trying to recover from it.
是吗？好吧，向你致敬。我发现管理一个就已经很多了。所以，“怀孕与生病”（Pregnant and Sick）有点不同。所以我几年前创办了它，我基本上把它当作一个资源库，提供给那些正在经历剧烈孕吐（hyperemesis）或试图从其中恢复过来的人。
So, it's not like I'm trying to do an episode every week. When I have an idea of, oh, okay, this exercise worked really well with the last client I worked with, or I met this person that shared a perspective that would have helped me so much while I was going through it, then I'll put an episode out. But it kind of sits on my sub stack. It's there for people that need it. It's not designed as a like week in week out podcast. I couldn't manage that at all.
所以这不像是我在努力每周出一期节目。当我有一个想法，比如，哦，好吧，这个练习在我上次合作的客户身上效果非常好，或者我遇到了这个人，他分享了一个如果我在经历这一切时能听到会对我非常有帮助的视角，然后我就会发布一期节目。但它基本上放在我的Substack上。它是为那些需要它的人准备的。它并不是被设计成那种周复一周的播客。我根本无法应付那个。
I love it. Okay, so it sounds like it's almost like a spoken blog almost. So things, when it comes to you, when it strikes inspiration, that's when you record. People will just hit subscribe, hit follow and it will ping into them when it's there. Yeah, exactly. And like I recommend it to people. So if I, it's another way of working with people that can't necessarily afford therapy with me. If I get an inquiry and they can't afford the therapy, but I know that they need psychological help for HG, then I know, okay, I've got like, I can't remember how many episodes it is now, like six or eight, which give you most of the psychoeducation I would give you
我喜欢它。好的，所以听起来它几乎就像是一个口述博客。因此当事情来到你身边，当灵感袭来时，你就会录音。人们只要点击订阅、点击关注，当它出现时就会推送到他们那里。是的，完全正确。就像我把它推荐给人们一样。所以如果我，这是与那些不一定负担得起我的治疗的人合作的另一种方式。如果我收到咨询，而他们负担不起治疗费用，但我知道他们确实需要针对妊娠剧吐的心理帮助，那么我知道，好吧，我有类似——我不记得现在有多少集了，大概六或八集——它们提供了我会在治疗中给你的大部分心理教育。
in therapy. It's not the same as the relationship, obviously, but it's got that information about how you advocate for yourself. It's got some mindfulness-based exercises that people find really helpful. And crucially, it kind of helps people understand that their mind plays a role. It's not the cause of HG, but it can make it a lot worse.
当然，这与人际关系不同，但它包含关于如何为自己维权的资讯。它有一些人们觉得非常有帮助的基于正念的练习。最重要的是，它某种程度上帮助人们理解他们的心理发挥了一定的作用。它不是妊娠剧吐的原因，但它会使情况变得更糟。
So for me, it's really important that everybody's empowered with that knowledge. And it's there for them whenever they need it. So I love that. And I love Substack as a platform because it allows me to do that, but kind of bracket it off. And then in the rest of my Substack, I talk about, you know, parenting children with additional needs and, you know, running a business around that, and lots of much broader issues that touch a lot of people that I work with. Thank you.
所以对我来说，非常重要的是每个人都能掌握这些知识。无论何时他们需要，它都在那里。所以我很喜欢这一点。我喜欢Substack这个平台，因为它允许我这样做，但又可以把它归类好。然后在我的Substack的其他内容中，我谈论的是，你知道的，抚养有特殊需求的儿童（育儿），以及围绕这些经营一项业务，还有很多更广泛的问题，这些问题触动了我合作过的许多人的心。谢谢。
I think it's worth thinking about the people that we surround ourselves with. So there's a Facebook group that you and I are both part of, which accepts qualified practitioners, psychologists in private practice. And I was part of that Facebook group for, I kind of watched for a while before I, probably for a couple of years really. And then it's funny that I've already mentioned Dr. Kara, because it was really down to Dr. Kara and my
我认为思考我们周围都是些什么人是很有价值的。所以有一个你我都参与其中的Facebook群组，它接受合格的从业人员、私人执业的心理学家加入。我曾是那个Facebook群组的一员，我观察了一段时间，在我加入之前，可能真的有几年吧。然后很有趣的是，我已经提到了卡拉博士（Dr. Kara），因为确实归功于卡拉博士和我的
husband that I started a business. You know, I can now say it's a business. At the time I was a bit embarrassed and ashamed to call myself a business woman, but that is where I am now. But Kara was always like, come on, do it. Like you're gonna find it, it's gonna be easier than you think it is. Like you would be brilliant at this. And I was like, Oh, no, I'm not enough. I'm not enough. I'm not enough. And then my youngest was starting preschool and I was in the NHS three days a week. So I was going to have two mornings off a week when he was in preschool. My husband was like, well, what are you going to do with your time then? And I was like, no, clean the house,
丈夫，我才开始创业。你知道，我现在可以说这是一项业务了。当时我有点尴尬，不好意思称自己为女商人，但这就是我现在的处境。但卡拉总是说：“来吧，做吧。你会发现的，这会比你想象的要容易。你在这方面会非常出色。”而我当时想：“哦，不，我还不够好。我还不够好。我还不够好。”然后我的小儿子开始上学前班了，我一周在NHS工作三天。所以我会有两个早晨不用上班，当他去上学前班的时候。我丈夫就说：“那你要怎么利用这段时间呢？”我说：“不，打扫房子，
have a massage, have a nap. And he was like, I don't think so. You could start your private practice. You could start that business. And I was like, I suppose I could, but I probably preferred my ideas. But it was those two spare, spare, spare mornings a week that was the start of my private practice. And interestingly, on the first ever morning when I was going off to clinic, I was standing at my kitchen sink crying.
做个按摩，小睡一会儿。”他说：“我不这么认为。你可以开始你的私人执业。你可以开始那项业务。”我说：“我想我是可以的，但我可能更喜欢我的那些想法。”但正是那每周空闲的、空闲的、空闲的两个早晨，成了我私人执业的开始。有趣的是，在我要去诊所的第一个早晨，我正站在厨房的水槽边哭泣。
And that probably doesn't surprise you because of the amount of people that you've coached through this. But I was like feeling, I'm not enough. I'm gonna not know the answers. I'm gonna be not good enough. I'm not worth the money that I'm gonna be paid for this. Because I was so used to being paid such a lower wage
这可能并没有让你感到惊讶，考虑到你辅导过这么多人经历这个过程。但我当时的感觉是，我不够好。我不会知道答案。我会不够优秀。我不配得到为此支付给我的报酬。因为我太习惯于在NHS中获得那么低的薪水了
in the NHS comparatively hour by hour. And so I just had this massive sense of just, yeah, that imposter syndrome not being enough. And you know, I managed to pull myself together and get to through my first, you know, clinic, which was two people. And then I had to race back and get my youngest from school. But it was so much less than I'd been used to working in the NHS actually. That doesn't, I don't mean to sound that dismissive of the work I was doing, but you know, they wouldn't have met the criteria for the NHS,
相比之下，按小时计算的薪酬确实低得多。所以我当时有一种巨大的感觉，就是，是的，那种冒名顶替综合征，觉得自己不够好。你知道的，我设法振作起来，完成了我的第一次，你知道的，诊所工作，那是两个病人。然后我不得不飞奔回去从学校接我的小儿子。但实际上，这比我在NHS习惯的工作量要少得多。我这么说并不是想贬低我当时做的工作，但是你知道的，他们可能不符合NHS的标准，
but they were still suffering, they were still distressed. And the skills I needed came to me readily and I did a good job and I was really surprised. Yeah I recognise that feeling when I first got positive feedback from somebody in private practice I was literally blindsided by it. I was like what I did well but you know I think that's part of what our training does to us. I think it really does make you think less of your skills. I think there's a prevailing culture that everything we know is just common sense and we don't really know anything.
但他们仍然在受苦，他们仍然感到痛苦。我所需的技能很自然地浮现出来，我做得很好，我真的很惊讶。是的，我认得那种感觉。当我第一次从私人执业的某个人那里得到积极的反馈时，我简直被打了个措手不及。我当时想：“什么？我做得很好？但你知道，我认为那是我们的培训对我们所做的一部分影响。我认为它真的会让你看低自己的技能。我认为存在一种普遍的文化，即我们所知道的一切都只是常识，我们其实什么都不知道。”
And actually, you should be proud of the skills that you have and the qualifications that you hold. And actually, other people do respect those enough to pay for them as well. And I think it's important that we try and infuse that in the younger people coming up behind us. And whenever I talk to people, whenever I have the opportunity to talk to trainees or assistants or aspiring assistants, I'm always really trying to talk them up because they naturally already are talking themselves down. I think it's a big problem. So I'm not surprised by that at all. No, but I am saddened by it. Yeah, and in the whole of my doctorate, I qualified in 2011. My first private practice
事实上，你应该为你拥有的技能和持有的资格感到自豪。而且，其他人确实足够尊重这些技能，并愿意为此付费。我认为重要的是，我们要努力将这一点灌输给在我们身后成长起来的年轻人。每当我与人交谈，每当我有机遇与实习生、助理或有志成为助理的人交谈时，我总是非常努力地赞美他们，因为他们天然地已经在贬低自己了。我认为这是一个大问题。所以我对此一点也不感到惊讶。不，但我为此感到难过。是的，在我整个博士学习期间——我是2011年取得资格的——我的第一个私人执业
client was 2019. So that's eight years later. But in the whole of my training, private practice wasn't really mentioned at all. Most of the people coming to teach us were working in the NHS. Some maybe had a side hustle, but yeah, most were working in the NHS. And yeah, like we had one specialist workshop in the third year that you could opt into about private practice. That ended up being so massively oversubscribed. But that was it, you know, one day talking about private practice. But, you know, I think times probably have changed quite a lot since then, especially when I graduated, there were no jobs. Of my cohort of 16 people that graduated at that time,
客户是在2019年。所以那是八年之后。但在我的整个培训过程中，私人执业根本没有被提及。大多数来教我们的人都在NHS工作。有些人可能有一份副业，但是的，大多数人都在NHS工作。是的，就像我们在第三年有一个关于私人执业的自选专业工作坊。结果那个工作坊超额预订得非常厉害。但也就仅此而已了，你知道的，就一天时间谈论私人执业。但是，你知道，我认为从那时起，时代可能发生了很大的变化，特别是当我毕业时，根本没有工作。在我那一届16个同时毕业的人中，
three people had jobs to go to because of the recession at that time. Three people. And it took me until the start of December to start my first qualified job because there was just no jobs as an end result of the recession from 2008. Oh my goodness. So I think that probably changed the narrative around that stage really because the NHS is certainly for training doctorates for the clinical psychology route.
只有三个人有工作可去，因为当时的经济衰退。只有三个人。直到12月初，我才开始我的第一份合资格的工作，因为2008年经济衰退的结果导致根本没有工作。哦，天哪。所以我想这可能真的改变了当时围绕这个阶段的叙事，因为NHS，至少对于临床心理学路线的博士培训而言，
They have no expectation currently of you having to stay in the NHS after you qualify. They can't, because they can't guarantee you a job. You know, I actually, the trust that trained me didn't have any jobs when I qualified. I ended up in a children's trust, you know, 26 miles up the road. So you don't owe any allegiances. And I think that was kind of quite important to me at that stage to think, well,
他们目前对你在取得资格后必须留在NHS没有任何期望。他们不能，因为他们无法保证你能获得一份工作。你知道，实际上，培训我的那个信托机构在我取得资格时没有任何工作。我最后落脚在一个距离公路26英里远的儿童信托机构。所以你不需要对任何人效忠。我认为在那个阶段对我来说这相当重要，心想，好吧，
you know, I was ready to be an NHS employee in the trust that had trained me, but they couldn't sustain their end of that bargain that was never written down, you know? stay in their end of that bargain that was never written down, you know? Yes, and I do think that's important. And I think, you know, for different reasons. So when I qualified, there were plenty, I think, of band seven jobs available. And I think, you know, looking around, there probably are at the moment. But there's nothing if you wanted to go above that, really. And I think that's another thing, like the NHS doesn't look after your career progression at all. And actually, you know, I'm not an expert on any
你知道，我准备好成为培训我的信托机构里的NHS员工了，但他们无法兑现他们那从未被写下来的承诺的那一端，你知道吗？坚持他们那从未被写下来的承诺的那一端，你知道吗？是的，我确实认为这很重要。而且我认为，出于不同的原因。所以当我取得资格时，我想有大量的七级（Band 7）工作可供选择。而且我认为，放眼望观，现在可能也有很多。但如果你想超越那个级别，真的就什么都没有了。我认为这是另一件事，就像NHS根本不照顾你的职业发展一样。事实上，你知道，我对这些事情根本不是专家，但我知道有些人他们得到了晋升，结果却被告知他们必须减少工作时间，或者他们的养老金缴款增加到了他们不得不支付很多额外税款的地步，这意味着他们在财务薪酬或职业满意度方面永远无法真正取得任何进展。在NHS中，最让我感到震惊的是，我从未遇到过一个担任顾问职务的人被允许全职工作。这根本不会发生。所以这就像是：哦，所以你其实永远无法在NHS里赚到大约5万英镑以上，因为一旦你达到了他们必须付给你那个薪水的级别，他们就会把你的工作时间砍掉，我认为这出于两个原因是很糟糕的。首先，这对个人来说很糟糕。我认为我们都需要职业上的进步，以便感受到那种成就感，正是这种成就感让我们作为个人和专业人士不断成长。但我也非常关切它对我们看待心理健康的方式所释放的信号。如果你拒绝让拥有经验、领导团队的心理学家全职工作，你不允许这种情况发生，那么心理学对你来说到底有多重要？我只是觉得，这非常非常清楚地表明了心理学在我们在公共部门拥有的心理健康系统中实际上是如何被看待的
of this stuff at all, but I know that there are people that they get promoted and they end up being told they have to work less hours, or their pension contributions go up to the point where they're paying lots back in extra tax which means that they're never really getting any progression in terms of financial pay or really in career satisfaction. It always really shocked me in the NHS that I never met somebody in a consultant post who was allowed to work full-time. It just didn't happen. So it's like oh so you can actually never earn above about 50 grand in the NHS because as soon as you get to a grade where they would have to pay you that they slush your hours down and I think that's terrible for two reasons. First it's terrible for the individuals. I think we all need progress in our careers in order to feel like
根本不了解这些东西，但我知道有些人晋升后，最后被告知他们必须减少工作时间，或者他们的养老金缴款增加到他们不得不支付大量额外税款的地步，这意味着他们在经济薪酬或职业满意度方面从未真正取得任何进展。在NHS，最让我震惊的是，我从未遇到过哪个顾问职位的员工被允许全职工作。根本没有这种情况。所以这就像是，哦，所以在NHS里，你的收入实际上永远不可能超过大约5万英镑，因为一旦你升到必须付给你这个薪水的级别，他们就会把你的工作时间砍掉。我认为这很糟糕，原因有二。首先，这对个人很糟糕。我认为我们都需要在职业生涯中取得进步，才能感觉到
we've got that sense of achievement that kind of keeps us growing as people and as professionals. But I also am really concerned about what it says about the way that we view mental health. If you're refusing to have experienced psychologists who are leading teams their full time, you are not allowing that to happen, then how important is psychology to you really? I just, I think it is very, very indicative of how psychology is actually viewed
这必须改变。我们必须为这种改变进行倡导。我认为我们能做到这一点的唯一方法就是树立一个更好的榜样。我的一些教练客户在这方面做得非常出色。我辅导过运营自己服务的人，他们将地方当局甚至是NHS资助的客户接入到他们由心理学家主导的服务中，并且展示了当心理学家被允许正常运营一个服务时——全权负责那个服务——他们能把工作做得多么出色。所以，是的，我认为目前公共部门的运作方式存在太多错误，
in the mental health system that we have in the public sector, and it must change. And we must be advocating for that change. And I think the only way we can do that is by showing a better example. And some of my coaching clients are doing an amazing job of this. I've, I've coached people that are running their own services, who are accepting, you know, local authority and even NHS funded clients into their psychology led services, and showing what a blooming good job psychologists can do when they're allowed to properly run a service, like full time be in charge of that service. So yeah, I think there's so much wrong with how the public sector is run at the moment that
盲目地对它忠诚可能对任何人都没有帮助。但这并不是说我不想在NHS多待一段时间，如果生活允许，我有一天可能会回到那里。我认为我们不需要把它看作是一条巨大的鸿沟，但我认为你需要做的是思考你的价值观以及你现在需要什么，并确保你的需求得到满足，并且你能够通过工作践行你的价值观，这可能对你来说是一个混合模式，可能看起来只在NHS工作，也可能看起来只独立工作。只需保持开放，保持开明，并立足于对你的执业重要的事情
being blindly loyal to it isn't probably helping anybody. But that's not to say I would have liked to have done longer in the NHS and I might go back to it one day if life allows me. I don't think we need to see it as this big divide but I think what you do need to do is think about your values and what you need right now and make sure that your needs are met and that you're able to live your values through your work and that might look like a hybrid for you, it might look like working only in HS, it might look like working only independently. Just be open, be open-minded and sort of ground yourself in what's important to your practice
以此作为你的北极星，而不是把自己局限在不去思考任何选项。哦，罗丝，老实说我可以跟你聊很久，我觉得我们现在才刚刚触及表面，所以我可能不得不在今年晚些时候再次邀请你回来，把这作为这期节目的引子，但我们也许会在今年晚些时候直接深入探讨其中的一些内容。谢谢。你能告诉我们，大家可以通过哪些方式更多地了解你，也许是如何在社交媒体上关注你，比如如何关注你的Substack？
and use that as your North Star rather thaning yourself off from thinking about any options. Oh, Rosie, I could honestly talk to you for ages, and I feel like we're only just, you know, scraping the surface of this, so I might well have to invite you back on later in the year to have this as the introduction to this, but we'll perhaps go straight in on a deep dive for some of this stuff later in the year. Thank you. Could you let us know, you know, about ways people can learn more about you, perhaps how they can follow you on social media, how to follow your sub stack, for example?
所以如果你正在考虑进入私人执业，我们拥有你需要的一切，包括在 psychologybusinessschool.com 上提供的一个免费检查清单。所以关于私人执业的内容，去那边看看吧。目前我在我的Substack上也相当活跃，它就叫“罗丝博士”（Dr. Rosie），出版物名称是“了解你的心灵”（Know Your Mind）。所以你应该很容易在那里找到我。在那上面，我谈论的是商业和育儿中更个人化的一面。这也是你会找到我关于妊娠剧吐的“怀孕与生病”相关内容的地方。所以如果你愿意的话，那就是我的社交媒体大本营，但我也在LinkedIn上，名字是Dr Rosanna Guilderthorpe，我还活跃在Instagram上，账号是 @RosieGuilderthorpe
So if you're thinking about going into private practice, we've got everything you need, including a free checklist over at psychologybusinessschool.com. So for private practice stuff, hop over there. I am also quite active on my sub stack at the moment, which is just Dr. Rosie, the publications called Know Your Mind. So you should be able to find me quite easily there. On that I talk about the more personal side of business and parenting. And that's also where you'll find my pregnant and sick stuff around hyperemesis. So that's kind of my social media home if you like but I'm also on LinkedIn as Dr Rosanna Guilderthorpe and I'm on Instagram as at Rosie Guilderthorpe which is like
这主要是关于心理学商业学校（Psychology Business School）的商业相关内容，以及用于更多妊娠剧吐内容的 @thepregnancypsychologist。所以，是的，我在很多地方都有账号，但Substack可能才是我的大本营。非常感谢你抽出时间，也谢谢你今天能来，尽管你感冒了，你表现得好极了。所以非常感谢。非常感谢邀请我。这真的是一段非常愉快的时光。哦，彼此彼此。谢谢你，罗丝。非常感谢邀请我，这真的是一段非常愉快的时光。哦，彼此彼此，谢谢你，罗丝。哇，罗丝博士是一个多么有吸引力且充满鼓舞力量的业界翘楚，即使在她感冒的时候也是如此。谢谢你抽出时间，罗丝。请务必去关注罗丝的所有社交渠道，这些渠道已经显示在屏幕上
my businessy stuff around psychology business school and at the pregnancy psychologist for more of the hyperemesis stuff. So yeah, I'm lots of places, but Substack is probably the home. Thank you so much for your time and thank you for turning up, even though you've got a cold, you've done amazingly well. So thank you very much. Thanks so much for having me. It's been a real pleasure. Oh, likewise. Thanks, Rosie. much for having me it's been a real pleasure. Oh likewise thanks Rosie. Wow what an engaging and inspiring powerhouse Dr Rosie is even when she has a cold. Thank you for your time Rosie. Please do go and follow Rosie on all of her social channels which have been on screen
并且也在节目简介中。如果你想获取她提到的检查清单，请务必前往她的网站。你觉得我和罗丝博士再次聊聊会有用吗？如果是这样，你希望我回答什么问题，或者你希望我们涵盖哪些内容？请在评论区告诉我，或者在社交媒体上给我发消息，我在所有地方都是 Dr Marianne Trent。如果你想通过请我喝一杯花草茶来表达感谢，以感谢我在这个播客中创作的内容，请随意。我的节目简介中以及所有社交媒体渠道的Linktree个人简介里都有链接，可以直接带你到那里。
and are in the show notes. And if you'd like to access the checklist she mentioned please do head to her website. Do you think it would be useful for me to chat with Dr Rosie again? And if so, what questions would you like me to answer or what would you like us to cover? Please do let me know in the comments or drop me a message on social media where I am Dr Marianne Trent everywhere. If you'd like to help by buying me a cup of herbal tea to say thank you for the content that I create on this podcast, please do. There are links in my show notes and in all of my social media channels where my Linktree bio will take you right there.
如果你想查看关于考虑全力投入私人执业的大师班，你可以通过访问我的网站 www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk 然后前往“与我学习”（learn with me）标签页来获取。如果你是一个有志成为心理学家的人，或者对于合格的心理学家而言，你很可能会喜欢阅读《临床心理学家文集》（the clinical psychologist collective），里面为撰写本文时的执业心理学家或心理学实习生提供了许多精彩的真实生活故事。这里还有《有志心理学家文集》（the Aspiring Psychologist Collective），它获得了极好的评价；如果你或你在乎的人是自闭症患者，并且想知道如何开始在心理健康领域开创一番事业，
If you would like to check out my masterclass on thinking about going all in into private practice, which you can access by going to my website www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk and then going to the learn with me tab. If you are an aspiring psychologist or for that matter a qualified psychologist you might well love reading the clinical psychologist collective which gives lots of lovely real life accounts for people that are practitioner psychologists or trainee psychologists at the time of writing. There's also the Aspiring Psychologist Collective which gets wonderful reviews and if you or someone you care about is autistic and wondering how you could begin to go about forging a career in
那么《自闭症选集》（an Autistic Anthology）绝对是最适合你的绝妙书籍。如果你希望获得更多支持、关怀、指导和建议来培育你在心理学领域的发展，请考虑加入“有志心理学家会员计划”（the Aspiring Psychologist membership），你只需每月30英镑即可加入。我们在研究、CBT技能和构思（formulation）、专业问题与模型、方法、理论、自信、面试技巧、技能与实践等各个方面都面面俱到。前往我的网站 www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk 并点击会员（membership）。你还可以前往同一个网站获取免费的心理学
mental health then an Autistic Anthology is the most brilliant book for you. If you would welcome some more support, care, guidance and advice for nurturing your development in psychology, please do consider the Aspiring Psychologist membership which you can join from just £30 a month. We have all of our bases covered in terms of research, in terms of CBT skills and formulation, in terms of professional issues and models, approaches, theories, confidence, interview tips, skills and practice and so much more. Head to my website www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk and click membership. You can also head to that same website and get your free psychology
成功指南，这也获得了很好的反馈。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你正寻找成为心理学家的道路，那就让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边，你将迈向成为合格心理学家的道路。这就是“有志心理学家播客”（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）成为合格心理学家，这就是有志心理学家播客，主持人是玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。
success guide which also gets great feedback. Thank you so much for being part of my world. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast Being qualified is the aspiring psychologist's podcast With Dr. Mary entrance There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
成功指南也获得了极好的反馈。非常感谢您成为我世界的一部分。如果您想成为一名心理学家，就让这成为您的指南吧。有这个播客陪伴在您身边，您将稳步迈向合格。这就是《有抱负的心理学家播客》成为合格的心理学家就是有抱负的心理学家的播客，主讲人是玛丽·恩特兰斯博士。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。